Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich führe durch die erste Ausgabe unserer Kurzversion von Chaosradio.
Chaosradio ist eine monatliche Radiosendung des Caos Computer Club auf Fritz, der im Raum Berlin Brandenburg auf UKW sendet
aber auch über Satellit zu empfangen ist und natürlich auch übers Internet.
Während unserer Sendung haben wir zusätzlich noch weitere Streams in verschiedene Formaten,
MP3-Streams, OGG-Streams die alle auf unserer Homepage unter chaosradioccc.de nachzuschlagen sind.
Chaosradio Express soll jetzt eine Lücke füllen zwischen den monatlichen Radiosendungen die ja auch recht lang sind
und nicht unbedingt jedermanns Sache mal ganze drei Stunden zuzuhören.
Chaosradio Express sind kurze, wöchentliche Sendungen die ungefair 10-15 Minuten lang werden
das müssen wir noch mal sehen vielleicht wirds noch mal nen bisschen länger wenn wir Interviews führen
aber wir wollen damit auch zwischen den Sendungen die Möglichkeit bieten aktuelle Informationen rund um den Hackerkosmos,
die Welt des Caos Computer Clubs und unseren Themen mitzubekommen.
Chaosradio selbst wird dadurch nicht überflüssig, die Sendung wirds natürlich weiterhin geben jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat
sollte uns nicht wieder irgendwas dazwischen kommen.
Von Zeit zu Zeit gibt's immer mal eine Abweichung aber im Prinzip kann man sich auf diesen Termin verlassen.
Wer ihn verpasst hat der hat ja dann auch immer noch den Podcast über den die Sendung dann verbreitet wird
aber wer es live mitbekommt ist natürliche immer eingeladen auch live anzurufen
zu den Themen Kommentare abzugeben, sich einzubringen, Vorschläge zu machen
außer der Möglichkeit es mit Telefon zu machen haben auch noch die Möglichkeit
in einer Mitmachseite vorab und auch während und nach der Sendung mitzuschreiben,
das ganze findet in der Wikipedia statt.
Wir werden das sicherlich demnächst mal auch in ein eigenes Wiki umziehen aber derzeit ist eben noch so.
Das werdet ihr dann schon mitbekommen und so ja gestallten wir dann immer eine möglichst interaktive Radiosendung mit euch und so soll das auch bleiben.
Chaosradio Express ist die Ergänzung, das Chaosradio für zwischendurch und ich hoffe das das von euch angenommen wird.
Aus der Abteilung "Neuigkeiten" ist auch noch erwähnenswert die neue Ausgabe der "Datenschleuder".
Die "Datenschleuder" ist das 4 mal im Jahr erscheinende Fachblatt, das wissenschaftliche Fachblatt für Datenreisende
des Chaos Computer Clubs, gibt es auch schon seit gut 20 Jahren und es gibt immer noch ein aufrichtiges Team was für neue Ausgaben sorgt.
Dieses mal haben sie sich ein bisschen selbst übertroffen. Die neue "Datenschleuder" kommt zwar immer noch im bewerten DIN A5 Format
aber diesmal in der Optik eines deutschen Reisepasses daher sogar mit abgerundeten Ecken, ganz großartig
und das einzige Thema, normalerweise ist die Themenvielfalt sehr breit aber diesmal ist das einzige Thema
der neue Reisepass der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Der Überwachungspass, wie wir ihn nennen, denn der neue Pass, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat,
wird jetzt ab dem 01. November für alle ab dem 01. November beantragenden Menschen ausgegeben
und beinhaltet einen Mikrochip der alle Informationen des Passes auch elektronisch speichert.
Bisher gab es ja schon eine Maschinenlesbarkeit in Form von "OCR" also der leichten Einlesbarkeit durch
Textlesemaschinen, man merkt es ja immer wenn man bei der Einreise den Pass zeigt, dann wird der Pass kurz durch so eine kleine Schiene durchgezogen
das ist quasi das automatische Einlesen.
Um diesen Vorgang noch weiter zu automatisieren, wurde jetzt dazu übergegangen, in den neuen Pass RFID-Chips einzubauen,
was wir für überhaupt keine gute Idee halten auch andere Sachen halten wir nicht für eine gute Idee denn noch sehr viel größere
Bedrohung die von diesen Pass ausgeht ist das jetzt auch biometrische Merkmale gespeichert werden.
Das erste biometrische Merkmal was gespeichert wird das ist das Foto.
Da kann man ja sagen "Ja Ok Foto hat man immer drin" aber diesmal ist es eben so das das Foto aufgerastert wird
und das auch nicht alle Fotos akzeptiert werden, man darf da jetzt nicht mehr lächeln, man darf keinen Hut auf haben usw.
sonder man muss da irgendwie starr in die Kamera kucken damit man eben für die Computer auch maschinenlesbar wird.
Ziel der ganzen Sache ist ganz klar, eine automatische Überwachung, kameragestützte Überwachung durch Computer,
d.h. Kameras filmen das eigene Gesicht und erkennen an Hand dieser biometrischen Merkmale ob es sich
um die eigene Person handelt oder nicht, soweit zumindest die Theorie.
Funktionieren tut das überhaupt nicht, das haben Studien gezeigt unter anderen die Bio-P2-Studie die
(em) unsere Geometrieexperten beim CCC im Detail mal auseinander genommen haben und die Erkenntnisse daraus
durftet ihr schon bei der vor letzten Chaosradiosendung Nr. 106 mitbekommen
und wer jetzt Lust hat noch diese Ergebnisse schriftlich nach zu lesen kann die aktuelle Datenschleuder Nr. 87 auch bestellen...
per E-Mail z.B. ds@ccc.de, freut sich (äh) über neue Abonnements oder eben auch über Einzelbestellungen.
Später wird die Ausgabe auch irgendwann online verfügbar sein aber die Onlineverfügbarkeit ist immer etwas später...
ein paar Wochen als die gedruckte Ausgabe.
Vom 27.-30. Dezember 2005 findet in Berlin der 22. Caos Comunication Congress statt.
Der Comunication Congress das ist unsere jährliche Großveranstaltung, eine 4 Tages Konferenz dieses Jahr, bislang 3 Tage jetzt 4 Tage
wo es mehr oder weniger rund um die Uhr wild zu geht.
Wir haben ein großes Konferenzprogramm mit vielen Sprechern aus aller Welt,
(äh) internationales Publikum 75% aller Sprecher aller Vorträge sind auf Englisch gehalten
der Rest ist auf Deutsch und wir werden in den nächsten Tagen das Vortragsprogramm vorstellen im Web
und dann ihr auch selber mal einen Blick drauf werfen.
Wir möchten euch einladen auf diese Veranstaltung zukommen denn einerseits ist das, gibts da eine Mengen zu lernen,
auf der anderen Seite gibts ne Menge Spaß. Neben dem Vortagsprogramm gibt es noch unser großes Hackcenter
wo viele Leute mit Rechner anwesend sind und dort auch konkret was schaffen und ihre Sachen zeigen.
Wer also einfach Kontakt zur Szene haben möchte, kucken möchte was die anderen so treiben ist auf dem Congress auf jeden Fall
am dem richtigen Ort. Außerdem ist es ne sehr lustige Veranstaltung, viele verrückte Leute
aus aller Welt und ich kann euch das nur sehr ans Herz legen.
Informationen zum Congress finden sich unter www.ccc.de/Kongress/2005.
Wir haben auch einen Webblog eingerichtet, das sogenannte CCC Event Weblog was also auch über den Congress hinaus über die zukünftigen
Veranstaltungen des Kongresses... entschuldigung.. zuküftigen Veranstaltungen des CCC berichten wird.
Das findet ihr unter eventccc.de, dort findet ihr auch den Link auf das Wiki für den diesjährigen Kongress wo man sich jetzt schon
(em) ja eintragen kann, selber vorstellen kann was man gerne zeigen möchte auf dem Kongress,
wenn ihr Workshops machen wollt, wenn ihr einen kurzen Vortrag machen wollt von 5 Minuten Länge
denn gibts die Möglichkeit dort im Wiki sich einzutragen solange noch Platz dafür (em) vergeben wird, noch frei ist
und ja die Tage wird dann auch noch das Vortragsprogramm vorgestellt, das wird nicht mehr langen dauern
das ist jetzt nämlich weitgehend fertig daran wird sich wohl nicht mehr so richtig viel ändern.
Wir haben ein paar sehr schöne Überrauschungen denke ich, ein paar erstklassige Sprecher
aus aller Welt die auch teilweise noch nicht bei uns hatten, teilweise sind auch einige
wieder gekommen die letztes Jahr schon vorgetragen haben da möchte ich jetzt noch nicht vorweg greifen
gibt immer noch so ein paar last minute changes und man
ja man greift dann sich genau den raus der dann doch noch sich geändert.
Also hier in den nächsten Tagen Updates auf www.ccc.de verfolgen oder eben gleich auf das CCC Events Weblog gehen
und dort den Feed abonnieren dann habt ihr eigentlich alles was man wissen muss.
Das bringt uns dann auch ans Ende von diesem ersten Podcast. Ich hoffe das ganze war informativ für Euch.
Wir hätten gerne Feedback, wenn möglich per E-Mail mail@chaosradio.ccc.de
wäre die korrekte Adresse. Sagt uns was Ihr hier hören möchtet, wie Ihr das findet, was ihr scheiße findet
und dann wollen wir zusehen, dass wir uns da drum kümmern und das abstellen oder
besser machen oder was auch immer das werden dann sehen.
Okay, ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören. Bis zum nächsten Mal.